the Joe Rogan experience how does dry
ice work oh it's just frozen carbon
dioxide that's all so here's the
difference here's the difference you
have a block of frozen h2o and a block
of frozen co2 so there they are it turns
out the air pressure on earth is high
enough it's a sea level is high enough
to allow the ice to melt and sustain a
liquid state okay the co2 under air
pressure normal air pressure it wants to
melt but it can't sustain a liquid and
it goes straight to gas if we had much
higher air pressure you could you could
have co2 melt and have liquid co2 so now
watch what happen so-so okay kind of
blow your mind again this is just this
is really good stuff okay it's good like
physical chemistry so here you go
so watch what happens so what happens if
I reduce the air pressure okay well the
transition from ice to water is still
the same that's not affected but the
boiling point is affected as you know
cooking times have to be adjusted on
mountaintops because when you boil water
it's not 212 degrees depending on the
height of the mountain there's less air
pressing down that that's preventing it
from boiling okay the boiling point is
not some absolute fact about the water
it has to do with what the air pressure
is sitting above it if you have
extremely high air pressure water has to
go to a much higher temperature before
it boils so our so the boiling point of
water that's reported in all textbooks
is at sea level at one atmospheric
pressure that's how you get 212 degrees
if you start reducing the atmospheric
pressure it's 210 degrees 205 degrees
200 degrees 190 degrees 180 degrees 180
oh yes and so that's not as hot as 212
degrees so you got to cook the food
longer all cooking times are increased
for this reason so now watch I'm not
done with you oh let's keep reducing the
air pressure okay theoretical like
possible
no no Himalayas yeah but or take it up
you can ascend in some kind of copter or
some kind of device our air balloon or
whatever but I'm saying you can do this
experiment in a laboratory okay okay
you keep reducing the air pressure
boiling port keeps dropping it's a hard
in 70 degrees 150 or in 20 a hundred
degrees Fahrenheit eighty degrees
Fahrenheit fifty degrees Fahrenheit
forty degrees Fahrenheit thirty-two
degrees Fahrenheit holy shed what
happens the ice melts and becomes water
the water evaporates and becomes steam
and all of that's happening at 32
degrees there is an atmospheric pressure
for which water ice and steam coexist
and it's called the triple point of
water and all ingredients have a triple
point what is Mars Mars is very close to
the triple point of water so you can
have you can have a simultaneous bath in
certain regions of Mars a simultaneous
bath because the air pressure is so low
it's like one one-hundredth Earth's air
pressure it's very very low so you know
a place where a pot of water ice cubes
and steam are coming out all at once
it's at the triple point so so so here's
the lesson here is we live life in our
world at one atmospheric pressure at one
the room temperature atmospheric
pressure and we define what is normal
based on that life experience based on
how our senses interact with that
environment but the actual universe is
far freakier than what we that what our
senses are exposed our five senses are
exposed to on earth
[Applause]